I gotta talk about this the JetBlue
pilot yeah everyone's talking about this
story this week on a JetBlue flight a
pilot had to be restrained after he ran
down the aisles yelling say your prayers
now in the pilots defense
say your prayers is JetBlue slogan it's
on the plane now this morning the CEO of
JetBlue went on The Today Show and he
tried to explain why their pilot went
crazy yeah apparently the CEO was
blaming it all on JetBlue's new free
snack meth flavored Tara blue potato
chips you've had them they're good I
find them too messy yeah it's a messy
aftertaste yeah yeah I am
Dodgers you excited about the Dodgers
huh
yeah an investment group headed by Magic
Johnson has reached a deal to buy the
Los Angeles Dodgers yeah mad magic said
he won't make any major changes other
than the Dodgers will now play
basketball it's never a good sign when
the best athlete on your team is the
owner
I don't think sorry Hunger Games mania
continues
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I do now for hunger games
this is interesting there's the latest
on it after Twilight fans were called
Twihards Hunger Games fans have now been
dubbed hunger Ling's yeah meanwhile John
Carter fans are being referred to as
that guy who saw John Carter
[Applause]
hey Lindsay loewen's in the news Lindsay
Lohan's going to make a guest appearance
on the show Glee yeah yeah lowens going
to play a student that all the other
students suspect is a 45 year old narc
[Music]
I thought this was interesting a recent
report finds that a recent report finds
that pot smokers get into fewer car
crashes than drunk people then again
it's easier to see what's coming when
you're driving at 11 miles an hour
[Applause]
and that's only if you can figure out
how the car works first place the
steering wheels incredible